rescuers in central croatia are
searching for survivors after a major
earthquake struck tuesday afternoon
authorities say at least seven people
were killed and many others
injured the quake was the second to hit
the region in just two days the search
for survivors continued long into the
night
petrinia once a picturesque town not far
from the croatian capital zagreb
now a disaster zone
the 6.4 magnitude quake brought death
and destruction without warning
but the response has been swift the army
moved in to airlift elderly patients
from a hospital
in one damaged nursing home residents
lay on the floor as they waited for
their turn to leave
as the most vulnerable are evacuated aid
is pouring in
across croatia donations are being
collected for petrinia
and the surrounding area
we saw they needed help people are
coming from everywhere to bring food and
they need humanitarian aid now because
this won't be over anytime
soon
basic necessities have already reached
this shelter for people made homeless by
the earthquake
we know there are no words but we offer
our honest compassion
because to lose your loved ones in this
catastrophe
it's like going through hell down
the mayor was holding a press conference
when the earthquake struck
shortly before noon on tuesday the
cameras capturing the impact
[Music]
as rescue teams clear the rubble in the
dark of night
that moment seems a lifetime ago for the
people of petunia
let's bring in dali bart dobridge here
he's a journalist in
zagreb but tell us how are recovery
efforts going
hello well the recovery efforts went on
through the night
there are no reports of any more
casualties so seven people
have been killed uh we don't have the
count of the injured yet
uh there has been an outpour
of help as you said in the report
uh from people all over croatia uh with
uh thousands of people bringing food
and then blankets and so on and it's all
being
gathered by the red cross and sent to
petrania
the army has put up tents and
shelters for the people who lost their
homes and that is basically
everyone in the region uh of petrina
glena sisak and so on there are
thousands of people who are now
without shelter now i understand that
zagreb
was hit by another smaller tremor this
morning
are there any reports of further damage
there have been actually three
tremors since 6 15 which woke me up to
this morning
that was 4.8 and two smaller ones
after that um zagreb is is was
is i think fine because we are quite far
away it's 50 kilometers from
from from petrina and the epicenter was
again there uh there are no reports of
additional damage but since uh people
have left there
left their homes uh mainly uh
we hope that everybody is fine but there
have has been additional damage
with these uh uh um in these uh
earthquakes since the the structures are
uh
fractured and and weak how well prepared
is the region there for earthquakes like
this
well uh on one hand it's not
very well prepared because the
infrastructure is bad
we have seen cracked roads the area is
without electricity since the poles uh
fell down and uh and even phones have
been disrupted
uh the the this whole area has suffered
greatly in the war and has not recovered
since it was
30 years ago the house it's a relatively
poor region so the houses are not
well built many of them are
quite old those are as you said in the
in the in the um
these before uh those are it's a big
picturesque
town but uh it's quite old so the houses
are old as well
uh but on the other hand we have had a
lot of practice unfortunately and
the emergency services have reacted
really really well
uh and uh people know now what to do
donnie bohr thank you very much for
bringing us up to date there that was
journalist talib dobridge
in zagreb
thank you
you